Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Gaël !
Gaël ce n'est pas n'importe qui c'est un réal mon gars !
Mais tu réalises pas encore ce qu'il va t'arriver.
On est dans les studios de notrefamille.com. Ou je viens ici deux jours par mois pour réaliser des vidéos qui vont être diffusées bientôt.
Je crois dans quelques mois ou un truc comme ça.
-Oui voilà.
J'en profite comme aujourd'hui on est mardi pour faire la vidéo qui sort ce mardi parce que je suis un petit peu à la bourre.
J'ai lu récemment qu'il y avait un garçon, un jeune garçon qui avait aidé la nasa à trouver la dernière cité des mayas.
Il s'est rendu compte que dans les étoiles, si on les raccordait ensemble, ça faisait le tracé des cités mayas.
Et qu'il y a une étoile qui couvrait pas, qui avait pas de cité, donc il leur a dit : "Allez fouiller là-bas les gars !"
-C'est pas mal ça.
Et ils sont allés fouiller et ils ont trouvé.
J'ai trouvé ça magnifique.
Ce que je vais te demander Gaël, c'est d'imaginer que tu es en train de découvrir une étoile.
C'est à toi, c'est ton étoile à toi, c'est la tienne, personnelle. Et comme c'est toi qui l'a découverte,
c'est pas une cité maya que tu as découverte, c'est une étoile,
tu vas pouvoir lui donner un nom.
N'importe quel nom. Faut pas me le dire, évidemment.
Ça peut être n'importe quoi, ça peut être un nom d'animal, mais ça peut être aussi un objet du quotidien.
Ça peut être ce que tu veux toi. D'accord ? Tu ne me dis pas lequel.
T'en as un en tête ?
-Mouais
En temps normal t'en as un en tête. Regarde-moi, t'en as un en tête qui te vient, c'est sûr.
C'est sûr, ok. Truc du quotidien.
-Ouais.
-Ok
Moi je ne vais pas te regarder, je ne vais pas essayer de deviner quoi que ce soit, je vais juste marquer comment moi j’appellerais mon étoile si j'en trouvais une.
C'est ce qu'on appelle plus ou moins une prédiction.
Tu sais quoi, moi voilà comment je l'appellerais.
Ah c'est bien, c'est gentil de ne pas regarder, je vais leur faire voir ce que je suis en train d'écrire.
Moi voici comment j'appellerais l'étoile. Je vous promets pas que c'est comme ça qu'il va l'appeler
mais je pense que si on découvrait l'étoile en même temps, il y aurait des similitudes.
Est-ce que tu peux nous dire très fort, qu'on t'entende dans cette caméra, comment t'appellerais l'étoile ?
-Stylet
-Stylet, et quel nombre tu lui donnerais ?
-996
-Ok, est-ce que tu peux te retourner ?
Je suis pas à stylet, je suis pas à 996, mais je suis à stylo et à 596.
C'est pas exactement, euh, c'était combien, tu m'as dit ?
-996
C'est pas exactement 996 mais est-ce que t'es bluffé ou pas ?
-Ah quand même je sais, je sais pas comment t'as fait.
Moi non plus.
C'était plutôt culotté, je t'avoue de faire ça, comme quoi vous voyez, ça ne réussit pas à chaque fois.
Et je vous le prouve aujourd'hui, mais franchement je n'étais pas très loin, je suis content de moi.
-Bah c'est bien.
-Dans quelques semaines je leur ferais voir les vidéos que toi tu as réalisé avec moi.
-Ça marche, ok.
-Et demain on tourne donc on va rentrer se coucher, c'est ça ?
-C'est ça, grosse journée de tournage demain. Va falloir qu'on assure.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, si ce tour vous a plu, vous pouvez nous le dire dans les commentaires. Vous pouvez aussi me laisser un petit... Pouce en l'air !
On se sert la main, vas-y on est viril et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog, Ciao !